the house the gun Love Shack oh [ __ ]
my name is beer pop we got a BAM we can
do it is for ChaCha's oh yeah what man
sing Deborah touch us on why aren't you
singing you don't know our national
anthem
really why were you when they wait can I
jump down there without nevermind
Harnick Akiko are there's gonna be
shampoo nail that I'm definitely gonna
save here okay go conquer why does he
sound like a monkey I wonder if we will
get to keep that awesome hat that's
that's my main concern right now I don't
know about you but I feel like that hat
needs the same does it make me look gag
now
you're silly you just wanted to rhyme
with say in gaming it's a guy I
understand I do that Chisholm but there
was me just Ron concur Jesus Christ oh
[ __ ] not this
oh thank god then God know that I called
that [ __ ] the hatch went off come on
why would the hatch go on maestra ah nah
no jump cogito there's only one way to
do it
whoa I know good job
but this is going really well
kong Kiku is on fire
yeah that's the worst way to die it's
getting burned but I don't know I never
tried I don't want to try it I decide
but yeah I'm sure there's some way more
words I know in Hannibal Lecter the
villain like it gets gets its victim any
less dirty now then I feel like that's
probably worse let's go now oh no I paid
on them I guess they didn't like it well
I was trying to compliment them how do
those but oh those are future stages
[Music]
they took are very nice that money
Oh No what is the world coming to
I don't know the squirrel can't even go
to a dinosaur themed world without
hurting mugged by a bunch of prehistoric
brats hi give me my money back that's
[ __ ] I'm only moonmoon huh no no
ah touch again bow ah now that gives me
another idea I will peel man trapped
under jet scratch what terrible birthday
that's funny
pretty bad how would it affect you on
schmira I guess your gesture forgot oh
he's talking to wave fate I tried out
Rumble that's cool
why do they mix like English so do I get
one of those because he fell off
I could teach those gyros bad isn't less
awesome where is it how the hell would I
get over they I know a lot if I go over
here I thought it before you thought
about it don't try to look specs you
look really smart
especially without guys [ __ ] are you
gonna get on it or watch keep run
automatically there's money up there
woah wow this is awesome
alright Prez I just found out I've been
trying to like watch I've been watching
tutorials and all kinds of [ __ ] and
they're supposed I'm supposed to race
against those people or whatever but
apparently I'm supposed to press forward
to go faster and it's literally
impossible to reshef now we'll put you
on to catch up with them if you don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like I don't want
to [ __ ] oh snap
instead more are you [ __ ] on my
penis are you [ __ ] from your nipples
whatta
now we got the money now we do domani
jump no it opens money I love you
directed edited a detector doo da doo
doo de doo doo de dad dad
yes my name it my name is Maximus
Morpheus Peter Pan
squirrel of a Meredith broken Adam
[ __ ] now
Eddie haircut this is a guy a radio
right friends I hope something yeah I
like it
and appreciative audience hello
somebody's pleased to see me
con dog oh yeah I know I'm great yeah
hey I know that the beach oh [ __ ]
I knew it so funky so what's fun like a
ton boobies yeah that's that's sexy
that's really sexy oh hey oh they're
jiggling up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty [ __ ] zero as he's now that's
okay too watching
the audience going wild look at what the
[ __ ]
best audience simulator that quite
killer going on here but there seems to
be a door over there so I think I left
moving on over and that they make don't
go though
don't go there what okay they just jump
in the lava apparently it's nice
Oh [ __ ] K what the [ __ ] get this okay
well I guess we just go over to the door
I know they trick ya hey what's up oh
you going this way to like it
yeah I'll give my hand why you guys
that ain't no door but ain't no door
of yet
[Applause]
oh we're fine with doesn't sound good
what does sound good in your back ah oh
mama what dot oh it's the mom of the one
I killed probably I got the feeling I'm
gonna ride on it I'm probably gonna ride
on he shed his pads literally that's
wonderful okay
oh that's some door right there for
concave Oh in about the time Hank I left
good oh yeah oh oh he kills you what am
i hypnotized again okay my life everyone
knows this is what you do why didn't
they do this in Jurassic Park we are
riding him to glory my brows
[Music]
[Applause]
hey to the ball now no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no I want to say there
whoa
this game is so [ __ ] weird okay a tab
there we go hmm is he talking about her
boobs or me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's [ __ ] huge man look at him look
like the look of it I think that funny
in the big boys okay well I can deal
with us
[Applause]
no problem I think of that I think yep
okay he doesn't want to I wouldn't do
anything
oh hey that it what a brain man god damn
your breath scalpel always Brea's
Celebrezze you're so silly
another taunting me Bruce is not doing
it in
oh no that actually works let's don't
show your junk that's fine nah don't
want to see that okay big fun I think
it's time for our deaths whoa
what does that even mean
haha and then now I get all good okay
well that's fine
triple kill yeah it's only this guy left
wow that was easy
ah get them on that was out suppose
Navin Oh got a bigger bonus naturally
before will say about that no big cap
you show him big boy the border [ __ ]
face just retain his 30 tighter sir well
your [ __ ] life
Oh My giddy up I don't have a guinea I
get it
no bueno whoa that's a ha ha ha ha
shiny brush dirty and nobody well I
didn't make it in Maserati there was
your yeah I know you're not a vegetarian
but they could hopefully to veg looks
like it needs a bit of tenderizing belt
you know when I meet he knows what he's
me while I didn't even know what da [ __ ]
is so big he has a big boat you have a
big boat I'm sorry it's really big all
right so we need to cook him right is
that it all that shock weight since a
chakra holy [ __ ]
Oh shadow young too soon I did a barrel
roll oh no Dino Sato they don't Santa
ouch there we go vitamin-a Jack ah ah
that's gotta [ __ ] hurt oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh ha ha ha ha
[Music]
what's nasty that is not okay
did you not watch I'm adding it into DIC
and you've elecbyte his eyes either
oh he's gotta be pissed now but his dick
outro out I feel your pain but I'm gonna
fight em
[Music]
again how much can a man handle that is
the ridiculous well I'm gonna bite you
again by G's AK die oh you like that
don't ya
ah
that ain't right man that ain't right oh
you seize dick hahahahaha
what that [ __ ] really what happened huh
even [ __ ] enough boner ha ha ha my
secret
Juden Winship private pocket well slow
ends another incident in my day now oh I
think we got there and payables babe
with it
those babies it's time to get the summit
out of this maybe there's some cash up
there too well we live them hope
Bateson cash sounds good to me right you
I think this is where we say goodbye
oh I know we had a good time together
die I miss ya go up up with ya
right wait I'm daytime 5 cow Hey no I
wait what are you doing stop following
me go back nope I lose another movie
reference present no that's definite
[Music]
that good psychology
oh it works with these animals yeah
let's see babe seven cash big time
alright let's go in here what happens
now
hey where's she where are those big
babes that's big bands yep
hmm Oh what wakey-wakey
someone angong gone what are you so cute
[Music]
good for chicken Oh No Oh what nah
no I can work it out like apps Clifford
you break each other's hearts
no no helmet oh yeah yeah nice girl
I won't I'm out the drinks out what have
you heard about me Oh No
Yoga puts gravity here Yoga not like
goodbyes come on you go you go bye-bye
oh [ __ ]
I know if you all like my bad I always
love you it said on the text well the
cloud at the Phil the lining what does
the expression silver-lining mean wow
that was it that was a great episode
Alvarez enjoyed like I said let's go
come over that today
[Music]
hahahaha
[Music]